while researchers at the Henry Ford
Health System have released a new major
study of hydroxychloroquine they found
that the drugs early use against
coronavirus may cut the death rate in
half amazing
Fox panel contributor dr. mark Segal
joins us tonight to discuss this doctor
thanks so much for coming on this is
something we've talked about many times
we've heard about the horrors of
hydroxychloroquine from the media what
do you make of this study this is a
groundbreaking study Tucker I spoke to
dr. Steve calcaneus who is the chief
academic officer at Henry Ford health
systems and he said as you pointed out
that it cuts the death rate from kovat
19 and 1/2 and the 2,500 patients they
studied and they have another study
coming up 3,000 health care workers to
see if it can be used as a preventive
this is very big news and it's a very
big step in the right direction now I
also spoke to congressman Michael
Burgess of Texas today who's the
Republican leader of the house as you
know Subcommittee on health and he said
he's been getting calls from all over
the country
why isn't hydroxychloroquine available
for frontline use at a time when the the
Kovan outbreak pandemic is increasing in
texas and of course the answer he gave
is politics and tucker as you know I
gave it to my I had a cardiologist
prescribed it to my father and he got
parently got dramatically better and
I've given it to many patients in March
and April who got better a pair do two
hydroxychloroquine likely so why is the
emergency use authorization been
reversed on it this study may change all
of that Tucker there's a lot of pressure
on the FDA tonight to reverse that the
emergency use authorization now you can
prescribe it off-label but many
physicians according to congressman
Burgess also dr. Burgess for 30 years by
the way is that this pressure not to use
it so the FDA has to step up to the
plate here this appears to be a
potential very very usable treatment
early in the game it's been studied
against the virus it's cheap it's very
cheap actually it's less than 50% per
pill and it's been around for 50 years
we know its side effects doctors should
be free to use it it should be studied
further Tucker
it's very promising it's it's remarkable
you hate to see politics drive science
the Soviet model it doesn't work but
that's what's happening dr. Siegel great
to see you thank you thanks Doug